what's up World Julian here today I'm
working on a very exciting DIY project
inspired by some of my favorite foods
now I am trying to eat healthier this
year but I gotta have my Burgers and
Fries so today I'm doing a fun craft
project inspired by that dynamic duo and
I do want to tell you guys that the
reason that I had the time energy in the
creative juices to gather all the
inspiration and develop this new board
is all thanks in part to Turbo Tax with
Turbo Tax an expert will do my taxes
from start to finish ensuring that
they're done right so I can relax I love
Burgers and Fries so I knew I wanted to
make something for my kitchen table that
showed that love and my creativity I'm
choosing to keep it simple and retro
Feeling by just stenciling the sketch
and then painting that sketch red I'm
using a paint pen but you could use
acrylic paint glass paint or even
permanent markers to make the design
there is no limit here and it doesn't
have to be perfect I tell you the best
way to cut this rice when it comes to
doing taxes is by not doing it a Turbo
Tax expert can just buy with me and I
have more time to develop recipes and
come up with Inspirations rather than
worrying about my taxes so check them
out on turbotax.com to cut the stress
when you're ready to start your taxes
now that the base is all dried I'm going
to add some flowers that remind me of
crispy golden french fries this was such
a fun DIY to do and I hope it inspires
you at home to create something based on
your favorite dish